do please inform us your dog kalka  minute I will give you all the  information we have at this moment in  time I'm speaking to Chancellor Merkel  as there are likely a number of German  victims and also with the king of Spain  who happens to be in France on a visit  today it's a tragedy a new aviation  tragedy we will have to work to find out  all the causes of what has happened and  will obviously work closely with the  relevant authorities both in Spain and  in Germany and with the victims families  it's a test which we will pass because  it's a tragedy which has occurred on our  soil and we will look to see if there  are other consequences of the accident  which took place in a particularly  difficult area to access and I don't  know yet if there are any inhabited  areas there which are affected which we  will find out in the coming hours we  have solidarity in our minds as our  upmost thoughts